this is a very exciting video as we have
new footage images and information
regarding doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness prove it so
starting off with the new footage we
have a new clip of doctor strange saying
prove it he's saying this to america
chavez in an area which looks to be like
the city we can see people walking in
the background now it's possible he has
just met america chavez and she is
saying she has all of these powers and
so forth and then doctor strange in
return is saying okay prove it but to be
honest with the amount of footage and
information we have can't really predict
what the conversation is about anyway
moving on to the next piece of footage
we have a lovely new shot of wonder the
camera work here by sam ramey is just
unreal it's a really great shot here
this is an extended shot of wonder which
we have seen previously she is in deep
meditation and it's a really lovely
looking shot moving on we have more
stuff relating to wonder we have a new
shot of her right here and it's looking
very very nice now this image also came
with some information which i'll read to
you guys out now with elizabeth olsen
sorceress about to play a major role in
multiverse of madness we'll be seeing an
even greater display of her powers and
by the sounds of things we might get
answers on rivas she's really more
powerful than strange i don't know who's
more powerful than wonder says
multiverse of madness producer richie
palmer who comes out on top as the most
powerful being in the universe maybe
we'll find out at the end of the movie
as palmer hints there the paths of
strange and maximoff have barely crossed
an mcu so far save for the battle and
end game but for each of them multiverse
of madness should provide some serious
personal challenges particularly since
wonder gained possession of darkhold in
the final scenes of one division magnus
has many different definitions says
palmer it's madden and for doctor
strange to have to watch the love of his
life marry someone else and it's man and
then for wonder to have been told
there's a book and there's a chapter
about you and that book you should read
and secrets you don't know about
yourself for olson the film finally
offered her a chance to share proper
scenes with cumberbatch for the first
time i really was excited to do dialogue
with him she says i've really enjoyed
our constant conversation of analysis
and trying to understand where both
characters are coming from let the
battle begin okay so judging by this
interview i would say it's safe to say
we will see a battle between doctor
strange and wonder and there will be a
clear winner of who is more powerful and
who comes out on top of this battle or
perhaps we'll both just see great
displays of the power on this film and
then by the end of the film we can be
like okay wonder's more powerful okay
doctor strange is more powerful anyway
it's really exciting stuff and it's
really great that we're getting more
footage from the film and i can really
tell that sam remy is behind this film
it just looks nothing like mcu has seen
before i just can't wait for this movie
so with that out of the way let me know
what you guys think in the comment
section below and if you did enjoy this
video please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching